تم ايقاف بعض السياسيين البارزين على غرار
رئيس حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي والامين
العام للحزب الجمهوري عصام الشابي
القياديين بجبهه الخلاص المعارضه ما رايك
في هذه العمليه عمليه ايقافه
اولا التتبعات القضائيه التي تمت
ضدهم لم تكن بسبب انتماء اتهم الحزبيه او
بسبب ارائهم او مواقفهم هي تمت يعني بسبب
افعال
نص عليه القانون الجزائري وعلي اتحال من
الناحيه القانونيه وبوصف عميد المحامين
اقول وان كل انسان بيري الى ان تثبت
ادانته من خلال محاكمه تضمن الرهوف فيها
حقوق الدفاع وما دامت القضيه والقضايا
امام التحقيق
فهناك مبدا وهو وجوب احترام سريه التحقيق
واترك المساله للقضاء ليكون كلمته في
الموضوع هل هناك ما يثبت ان التحقيقات تتم
على افعال وليست على افكار
الحال يعني تحقيقات يعني كل
يعني شخص محالمه من التحقيق له لجنه دفاع
وله كم هائل من المحامين بالساده المحامين
الذين
يساندونه وينظرون على امام هذه الدواء
وبطبيعه الحال يعني حتى القرارات التي
يتخذها الحاكم التحقيق او قضاه التحقيق
ممكن تعن فيها امام المحكمه الاعلى درجه
وكذلك ربما حتى المحكمه هي تحت رقابه
محكمه التعقيب وبالتالي اعتقد ان الضمانات
القانونيه متوفره
والمفيد وانه عندما يقع عرض المحكمه
القضيه امام القضاء في سوره قرار التتبع
ستكون
المحاكمه علنيه وسيدلي كل طرف يعني بدلوه
سواء النيابه العموميه باعتبارها مسؤوله
عن الادعاء او المحامون هم المسؤولون على
الدفاع
الكلمه هي للمحكمه التي يجب علي ان تتحمل
مسؤوليتها كامله في اصدار احكاما عادله
من متابعتنا للاوضاع في تونس او في رد فعل
لشارع التونسي على بعض القضايا هل يمكننا
ان نقول انه عزف التونسيون عن الدفاع عن
الملفات الحقيقيه ولا هو عزوف عن الدفاع
عن منظومه محدده بدليل انه التونسيين
تعاطفوا بشكل منقطع النظير على قضايا
الشباب غير المسيس مقابل فشل منظومه ما
قبل 25 مليون يوليو في تجميع الدعم من
الشارع التونسي
لا يرى المشكل السياسي في تونس هو يعني
ثم تراكمات وقعت يعني منذ عقود
والعمل السياسي يعني كان تقريبا مغيب من
[موسيقى]
ولم تتكون يعني طبقات يعني سياسيه
في كامل المجتمع التونسي بحيث اختصر العمل
السياسي على العمل النخبوي ولذلك يعني
كانت هناك نخب في واد وبقيه يعني الشعب في
وادي اخر واعتقد هذه الفرصه يعني سوف تمثل
منعرج هام بالنسبه للعمل السياسي في
المستقبل وهو ان من يريد يعني
يعني القيام بعمل سياسي عليه ان
يلتحم بالطبقات الشعبيه والاحزاب تقوم
بتاطير المجتمع كما يجب ان لا يقتصر
عاملهم على النخبه وبالتالي يعني عند ذلك
سيكون لهم حضور في المجتمع وتاثير في
الانتخابات في المستقبل
همم